these exposed ridges and summits are
called
noon attacks this is an important
feature to know in the ice age
a noon attack is a landform swallowed
almost completely by the ice
with only a tip sticking through there
are these enchanting landforms these
ragged castles sitting out on the plain
and below thousands of feet of mountain
under the ice people could have used
these as stepping stones
hopping down the rockies and the coastal
ranges
we went up on them because it only
seemed natural
this is how you make your map you climb
you get a vantage
you see a head reaching the top is like
setting a compass point on the saddle of
this noon attack
i found a feather it had melted into the
snow
and nearby i found the bird's tracks a
raven
it landed up here and walked to the edge
of a cornice
i could see where it came from and where
it was going
maybe landing up here to rest its wings
and where it flew from the cornice i
could see the map
that spread below it i believe animals
had a lot to do with
moving humans into this continent people
would have come
down the kelp beds of the coast and
skinned boats
fishing and hunting the rich waters and
followed birds across the ice
you get swept up in migrations and they
pull you along
where did these animals take the first
people